you're listening to inside of you that
was an aggressive intro anybody start
over now do you know how I usually go
you're listening to inside of you I just
did something different I brought a
little energy to Mayo we'll get a vote
do you guys like the calmer you're
listening to inside of you with Michael
Rosenbaum Oh or do you like the big one
you're listening now see it's it's
mellow yeah they like the mellow and
they don't want an excited Rosenbaum who
wants an excited Rosenbaum my dad sure
didn't I was you know probably annoying
Sadd what the hell's this kid doing
bouncing off the [ __ ] walls it's been
a day man it's been a day folks I
usually take things in stride today is
the first day in 250 days that I didn't
meditate in the morning I just woke up
late wrong side of bed I think I cried a
few times this week just been it's been
a lot but I'm gonna meditate right after
we're done with this podcast and boy am
I gonna need it but yeah it's just been
you know I went to the Ronald McDonald
House and it's been on my mind and I go
every other Tuesday and I you know bring
movies and pizzas and stuff like that
and I met this kid we just connected and
his mom was there and you know terminal
cancer and he was a big Smallville fan I
just connected connected with him I
couldn't stop talking to him I could I
was interested in him he was just a
great kid and great positive energy and
I gave him my number and his mom my
number and I've been texting with them
and he went through a huge surgery
yesterday morning it didn't go as
planned
you know but he's a tough kid and I'm
not a big prayer I believe in like you
know hey there's many people who need
more things than I do my prayers I don't
need to pray for superficial [ __ ] so
this is one of the first times I did
pray and I said hey man there's one of
those Exorcist moments where I was like
take me take me I really was I was like
[ __ ] man this kid deserves life he
deserves happiness and he's I'll tell
you someone who goes going through all
this [ __ ] he's tough as hell he's a
cheerleader he's great showed me some
backflips he's doing on video he's just
a good kid Preston if you're listening I
love you buddy and you're uh you're in
my mind you're in my heart and let's
beat this freakin thing man
so great we had a great show today
before I get going on that I'll just
throw out a few things
thank you to all the patrons and my
patrons out there in the outro of course
say your names and by the way the
questions I'll ask my patrons certain
the certain tiers get to ask questions
for the guests so you know we picked
certain questions and so if we didn't
pick yours it's gonna happen the next
time and you know it's just a it's a
process as the Canadians say a process
Ryan that's what they say process yeah
yeah everyone else says process yeah no
we say process they say process yeah so
and also yeah that's that's what I'll
say about that a lot of good things
coming up going to Richmond for for a
Smallville convention their Galaxy Con
and February 28th 29th and then I'm
going to Jason man to produce the album
my album left on Laurel and we're gonna
do a live stage and on next Sunday night
which is the 29th earth first what is
that whatever the foot you know what it
is go look on stage it calm and check it
out if you want to watch
all right this just came in this is news
I'm doing a live podcast I've been
tweeting you guys out there and telling
you that I might do it my first live
podcast is gonna be in Austin Texas
I'm very excited it's at the north door
7:00 p.m. March 31st Tuesday my guest is
Zach Levi you know I'm from Shazam he's
been on the podcast
I'm so excited he's my first guest
tickets right now if you go online
before they sell out 25 bucks in Austin
at the north door you can go to inside
of you live.com slash so you could find
it there it will redirect you to that
Eventbrite link for the live podcast
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum
live in Austin Texas at the north door 7
p.m. with Zach Levi I hope you guys
check it out also you can go to the
website margin Walker presents calm and
that will redirect you there it's ma r
GI n Walker presents calm if you can't
find it but you'll be able to find it
I'm gonna post it on my links so a live
podcast in Austin I'll also be in Mexico
later in the month and month of March
with Tom doing a little Smallville
Knights and all that stuff so a lot of
cool stuff going on what else man like I
said crazy week but you just keep moving
you just keep moving and you're grateful
like the thing that keeps you moving is
like you see a guy like Preston it's
like really dude
you're gonna worry about your bad
day what was you who was so bad about
your day Michael that's how you feel
when you see you know you see other
people suffering and dealing with big
problems you're like taking this tried
man take it [ __ ] stride Rosenbaum
geez dude the guest today on the show
are Brian and Gianna Welch you know
Brian from corn it was the one of the
biggest days when he left the band and
people like why did he leave and it's an
amazing story and for those of you look
he left to find God and kind of like oh
why would I want to listen to this well
you do want to listen to this because
this is a fascinating story really about
not only a guy but his daughter who you
know he wasn't hurting himself by doing
all these drugs and things that he's so
open about and but his daughter's here
with him and it gets emotional man
it got emotional and were you
uncomfortable no but it was it was kind
of tough to hear because you sort of
hear about the effects of the rock star
lifestyle on the family and because I'm
sitting next to him he's got the tattoos
everywhere and I'm sort of looking at
those but then you can also see you know
the effects of his daughter yeah it
clashes
yeah the vulnerability it was it was
interesting and I really appreciate
Brian G and a big shout-out to Chris
talent for hooking that up Chris down a
great director friend of mine great guy
hooked me up with Brian and they came
over and they did a documentary which
will talk about what you guys need to
see it's pretty pretty amazing and
inspirational and I think you guys are
gonna really enjoy this interview so why
don't we right now
why don't we get inside of Brian and
Gianna Welch
it's my view
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience but most musicians especially
if you're in a band like Korn
like how are you not half deaf they are
yeah literally
um I wear earplugs every show these
fools Jonathan Davis our singer James
Shaffer monkey a guitar player
they don't wear earplugs ever ever well
they gotta be deaf I don't get it I mean
I gotta be but you don't see any like
you don't ever notice like I said hey
three times and they didn't hear it
that's incredible because you're like
that's it loud band Korn's loud it's
louder than any bit certainly louder
than air supply
do you know aerosol plays I think I've
heard sing a song from air supply Brian
Philip Welch does anybody ever call you
Brian Phil applause they just call you
head
my mom calls me head and my friends call
me Brian Fred's not shrewd or the other
way around outside their way around
does your mom ever say I hate when they
call you head when she gets mad she's
like head she does not know no I'm a
liar you and I have the same facial
structures we both have just longer
faces people said I read somewhere where
what look at my head I have a longer
stuff I have a big head you know many
times people tell me I have a big head
and that's how you were named head
because your band mates or whatever told
you that your head didn't look like it
belongs in your body cuz it's too big I
don't think that's the case because
you're taller and it works but I'm
saying that's that's the same thing with
me I've always had like people have said
you got a big head dude really
always Ryan do I have a big head of
course don't grow a beard cuz it makes
your face look longer and I just do it
anyway cuz you don't care to hear I
don't give a [ __ ] anymore
so what about uh no here's what happened
my my head grew before my body grew and
when I was teenager so my head like
turned into an adult and my body was
still a twelve year old it was like yeah
but so now I'm you know I've grown since
then
janay you have a perfect head oh thank
you you know in combination of genes
between your mom and dad her mom has a
skinny face to kind of not long but kind
of skinny so I don't know where you got
it
I got her crooked nose so I mean she I
don't think you cookin nose but let me
tell you something I like a nose that
you're my friend Chris McDonald he says
man I love a girl with a strong nose
like what does that mean he's like
strong you know it's a good you don't
have a butt like something bigger
stronger strong and one time there was
this girl who's a friend of ours in my
phone I had Jill strong cuz Jill had a
strong nose and I remember I wouldn't
matter when we met her Chris like that
goes got a strong nose I like that and
so one time we're at a bar I looked at
my phone and she saw her number and it
said Jill strong no that's my number
who's Jill strong I go no that's you
what what does that mean I go no it's
just like you strong you're like I look
to you like that girl's hot she's strong
I made it up on the fly covered it up
what if she listens she won't is this on
right now she's this life no it's not
like okay this was live listen the two
you were here because well first of all
my good friend Chris Dowling but
secondly well here's the deal I watched
this documentary and you know it always
sucks when someone says hey you don't do
your research and you have to watch an
hour and a half documentary I'd say
watch this movie that I'm promoting like
[ __ ] I'm gonna fast-forward through this
[ __ ] I mean I just don't have a didi I
don't have time time it's really good
it's like yeah I'm gonna sit back for
two hours in the middle of the day I
could barely watch a movie at night when
I'm sit on my couch and I have nothing
going on I get it but I watched it jazz
my assistants sitting across from me and
then I'm just I just started crying at
the end because there were like certain
parallels and I just felt like you were
so brave both of you in this documentary
so forthcoming in like it's so easy to
just you know sugarcoat it hide all your
secrets hide everything there's stuff
that's too embarrassing I'm not gonna
share it and I feel like you start to
divulge you start to tell everybody all
these things that you did and your and I
could see how hard it is for you and
then something tells me it's just that's
cathartic as you could get once once you
release that oh yeah I was just trying
to
be real first of all mm-hmm and it's
funny you say that to back up that this
I just did a podcast the other day and
the guy said look you know these people
said we need to link up together we need
to talk about you know doing some stuff
together so they got invited to go to
dinner with me and then they said it
sent the link and they said hey watch
this movie though you know before the
dinner he's like oh god I'm getting a
free dinner
well I better you know I better watch it
so I have some stuff to talk about what
not it's so same thing he watched it and
he was like holy [ __ ] we're doing we're
doing movie showings in my town and he's
setting them up right now so that's
exactly that's cool but you know not
everybody will connect with it but like
a lot of people have and so it makes me
feel I don't think you can't connect
with something like this because even if
you you know you haven't done drugs and
your party you're not a rock star it's
not really about all that as much as it
is a relationship it's about you and
your daughter and I felt like you were
just lost and you just couldn't you you
wanted to you saw like the other side
god I want to be a better dad I want to
be a better friend I wanna but it's that
struggle it's addiction and all that but
it seems like for someone to be able to
one day just make a decision and just
walk away from all the fame and all the
fortune all that I mean that's it that's
a huge thing but I think this relates to
normal people and I'm not saying you're
not normal I'm not you're more normal
now yeah but I think that like you know
it's the guy that's a workaholic I have
a friend whose dad works all the time
and he's a kid always working always
workers work work work work and he just
need and there's an addiction what was
an addiction so there's all these other
addictions out there yeah yours was
drugs and partying and you know so
everybody has that until you start to
learn to be present learned to have some
mindfulness learned that there's other
things that are way more important
because nobody gives a [ __ ] once your
day that's it that's it and so when you
say that it reminds me of a guy that was
giving me advice before I left before I
got sober he was like you know what no
one no one is that their deathbed going
I wish I would have worked tomorrow
yo sure would have toured the world more
in my band I wish
it's always I wish I could have spend
more time with my family you know yeah
yeah or some people may have done it
perfectly in there like I'm ready to go
I've done everything right that's
alright I'm gonna go what is it Neil
Young it's better to burn out than fade
away yeah yeah did you think that a lot
of times cuz Jenaya Jenaya is here and
we're gonna talk to you a lot about this
but did you feel like you know a lot of
times while you're partying or like I
don't even care I hope I party too much
and don't wake up were you were you one
of those who had those McCobb thoughts
of just like I kind of want to die I
don't care um the last two years of my
addiction yeah but it wasn't like I
don't care it was like I want to cease
to exist I don't want to breathe I want
to get up and feel this way anymore
but then I'd be like but I can't leave
her she's four or five years old and her
mom's out of the picture and I'm I'm the
only one that's you know I'm her
caregiver but what do I have to give her
she you know she'd probably she would
get over it if I if I died and someone
would raise her like whoever in the
family that's better person to me you
know know me so it was it was back and
forth it was never like I don't care I
want to leave and never wake up it was
like I just don't want to feel anymore
all right so look this documentary could
loud crazy love and you know anybody
could watch the story of corn and go
online and hear their music it's
everywhere you guys had huge success you
said one one part in the documentary
that you had too much money to fit in
the bank there's something like that
yeah those like an exaggeration you did
have that much money when you're talking
about a lot of money I'm always one of
those guys who think how much money did
he have cuz like you know I'm okay like
I'm doing okay I'm fine I have a house
you know when I think rock star money I
mean when you get residual checks were
you getting millions of dollars in
residuals no I was exaggerating what my
point was that in my head
I was thinking was I I bought everything
that I had to buy like I couldn't buy
anything anymore
I had the cars I had the house I had the
$200,000 pool the bridge going over a
waterfall every time like I got I got
nothing else to like buy I have all my
toys
I can never want
and I was just like what do I do now you
know it was just uh I don't know and
then I then I had self-hatred because
I'm like I'm not thankful like any great
oil yeah I'm hate I'm just like I'm a
whiny little rock star you know oh I'm
depressed
oh I had every yeah every 213 okay I
said this to a therapist I said I don't
know I feel like I've done it all this
is me who's done one millionth of how
much you've done and toured in all the
place but I was like listen I've been to
Disney World so many times I just it's
just I don't know if it's as fun is it
anymore
and I you know going to eighties
concerts and I started naming these
things that people would just laugh at
me I'm like you know I did it and
they're like but maybe one day you fall
in love with somebody and really just
want to show them all the things that
you love and then you'll enjoy it
through them and I'm like oh my god how
did I not see that right right
immediately made sense so that I think
of your daughter I think of Jenaya going
she's five she's six all these things
that I get to do to go over the world
everything I I want to do with her
I don't explore with her right but I was
stuck in my you know it's like that
light went off when when he or she said
that to you oh yeah I'm like first I
thought how am i that's stupid
come on how do I not realize that but
that's how unaware I was of who I was
and what I really wanted and then when I
thought I could share this with someone
and that started to open the doors so
the mental blocks were so yeah blocked
in our thinking man it's just crazy the
pride and though it's like one sentence
from one person even a stranger can
shift your life like that I'm in a good
spot now and I still get in those ruts
where you know your your mind comes in
it's cloudy and you're just like feeling
and then someone says something and I'm
like I mean just happen the other day I
can't think of what it was but oh yeah
they were death look there's a lot of
death happening and and I'm just like I
could suffer intense lately you know
with families and people who mean a guy
no just had his brother-in-law murdered
and you know over a drug deal and then
they cut up the body and try to burn it
to for evidence and it was just like I
can't take it and
until I'm making a murderer right you
know and it's just how it's hard to take
man and and someone just said something
about the other side and it's like
viewing things from here the horror from
here or on the other side where all the
pain is gone and resting a piece and
it's like what's our perspective we're
only here for a little bit of time so
why are we focusing on the horrors of
this life when the next life is so vast
and pain tree that's always the thing
it's the the not knowing you know yeah
you know we don't know I mean obviously
you know you found religion you found
God and you have an idea of where you're
going you know and a lot of people out
there I have friends were atheists and I
know probably a lot of guys and your
band are and people in music whatever
they're all around even my grandmother
goes I just am I gonna see my you know
my husband again cuz my grandpa just
passed and I'm like and this was with
conviction I wasn't making her feel but
I go yeah you will I think you will
I really just right there was something
in me there's like hey there's something
bigger there's something better there's
something there's something more out
there you know and we can get into that
but I want to go back to the to the
documentary because I felt like I'm
about to watch him relapse something's
gonna happen Brian's gonna relapse
how does because you know you leave the
biggest band in the world you you know
you're making tons of money you know
your bands like [ __ ] this and then now
you're struggling a little bit and
you're finding out Oh questioning
yourself did I do the right thing I'm
sure that went through your mind right
oh yeah totally
so and I was like expecting but relapse
relapse maybe relapse after the
documentary
maybe I kept thinking but but you
haven't I relapsed before well here's
the thing I didn't really real apps
because I never said I was gonna quit
but I would oh do meth or coke or
whatever and then not okay I'm not gonna
do it for a while then months would pass
and I'd do it again
so does that count as relapsing cuz I
didn't try to shinny a really does that
count um no because there was no
definitive like I'm quitting I'm done
yeah yeah I agree with her so but I did
relapse when so I quit I you know I
found my spiritual life and and I was
doing that for a while and then I wrote
in my book they didn't put it in the
movie but I
wrote in my newest book that I started
having wine with some friends that just
you know had some wine with dinner right
and I'm like one glass that's it that's
all I'm gonna do one and then like a
couple weeks later I was like one big
big glass that's it two glasses three
weeks later three glass and then
elephants and then I was in doing shots
and for two months and I was like it
just never ends well I can't drink man
why can't we just drink responsibly
because some people just can't I have
friends
but I'm like you shouldn't drink
honestly I can drink I could honestly
drink as I don't look to get hammered
I don't need and my personality doesn't
change but I have friends I don't know
who they are I don't know who they are
when they drink they shouldn't drink
they do stupid things when they drink
and they always regret it and they're
always filled with guilt so I'm like I
don't know you I don't I don't like when
you drink I don't like being around you
when you get hammered and can't control
yourself I just can't I can't do it it's
crazy you can't control yourself no but
but then I was like I'm gonna quit in
like next month or and two months from
now I know I can't drink any more but
while I'm drinking I'm just gonna keep
going right so I set this time and then
I battle myself but yeah so that was a
relapse drugs no not once
no and you know yep I mean yes when you
talk everyday mostly um texts don't like
texts like every few days and then we
see each other at least once a month
cuz I'm living in Lafayette Indiana
right now Lafayette is near where the
youth center was yeah because I'm also
from Indiana I grew up in southern
Indiana
Evansville yeah that's so far yeah did
you know Michael Jackson in the Jackson
5 I did not know them they live down the
street really yeah I Gary Gary Indiana
Gary Indiana gue and do you know all
right so look I mean there's so many
things I want to talk about but like
this relationship you know you're born
did you say relationship well it was a
relationship for a while
that should be our term now well our
relationship
it finally became a relationship Wow
love that you were born in 98 yes I want
you you born in 1902 in the math life
huh now watch and you can feel like you
could see the love you could see like
how much she meant to you see that's a
nice house
she is the angel sent from heaven to get
me healthy honestly but I think also I
might be dead if she wasn't here I might
not have cared to get right I think
that's probably you know I'm gonna say
that's entirely true I don't think he'd
be with us right now if you didn't have
her cuz I wouldn't have cared what do
you care for what do you care for you
took her away from her mother you came
home while you're on tour and her mother
had were there really a neo Nazis in her
house like heads yeah skinheads are
living in your house walking around as
you're a little girl
and you came home to this that she's
happy and you all she know I heard about
it they talked about it and a friend
told me some things that was going on
and then I I sent a message well there
was no messages I called left a
voicemail like I'm coming to get her I
don't care who's there that I came back
and because of the message they bolted
and left her with a babysitter who was
watching her at the time I can kind of
didn't see these guys know if you would
have walked in to freaking this mess do
you think he would have attacked these
guys well my friend Donny big Donny yeah
he borrowed Big D he borrowed a gun from
my friend Rob so it was a thing where
like he had it in his in his pants just
in case cuz these guys were gang members
you know they probably even if they're
tweaking they probably would have been
like oh this is his kid you know take
your kid you know but I don't know what
would have happened it was just like I
had to get her away from that madness
and so nobody was there except a nanny
do you remember no I was two or three
yes you were just a little girl yeah and
you took her and you went back on tour
with her yep but it was it was pretty
fun
she was like running around you look I
don't know I mean you're too young to
remember these things I mean I remember
um being on tour a lot I remembered they
were they were always so sweet to me
like they're they're security guards in
whatever would push me around the
stroller and take me to parks and stuff
so I remember those things yeah how long
did that go on um that was not that long
actually it was like a month or two or
something like that then she would come
out like sporadically but it wasn't like
a constant hey you're going the road
with me for a year or two well who'd she
stay with at that point so when she was
on the road we had we had a nanny it was
actually a dancer from Britney Spears
tour they were off the road for a little
bit yeah my tour manager I said oh oh in
my tour manager my tour manager was
dating her and she's amazing and and
then we went we went home that guy Donny
Big D his family there they had kids
like kind of the same age and everything
and so we we just it was like my my
parents her grandparents his family and
we just did what we could you know right
while I was touring so that was another
like three or four years before I
figured it out look I'm leaving and I
gotta be home with this kid I want to be
home with this kid how old were you when
Brian decided to you know quit the band
um I was six years old six years old so
you remembered when you're six you can
remember a lot of things yeah I I
remember it like it was yesterday
honestly and you couldn't believe it
when it happened right yeah this little
girl and you talked about it you weren't
spiritual really you weren't religious
when I let this happen no no not at all
so you just went to a college or high I
was told about Jesus when I was 12 and I
actually just prayed to him once and
then I prayed like when I was 12 years
old then I prayed again at 19 and I was
like lord please don't let me go bald
and there's like two prayers in a decade
there's a lot of those prayers I think
the God hears a lot of those prayers
please don't let me go bald now you have
hair to your butt so great job that's it
so yeah
[Music]
inside of you is brought to you by
squarespace Ryan have you ever wanted
your own website right everybody wants
their own website they want to start a
new business they want it to stand out
they want and I don't know what I'm
doing
I mean in general I don't know what I'm
doing I need general so how do this so
how am I gonna do
[ __ ] website you should probably find
a place that can do it for you with some
nice templates did it's so easy this
they make it so easy and so affordable
that you have a cool idea they turn it
into a new website showcases your work
you know blog or publish content
whatever you want even sell products and
services of all kinds you go to
Squarespace Squarespace you promote your
physical or online business do I sound
angry no well I'm not angry but I you
know I think this is such a it's a good
product
you know you think something you dream
it you make it okay with Squarespace
sure that's what you do and I like that
you know they have these beautiful
templates created by world-class
designer so it's not some guy that
you're getting it like but maybe back
home room from analytics that help you
grow in real time they have built in
search engine optimization free and
secure hosting 24/7 award-winning
customer service it's pretty right there
in front of you make it yourself easily
create a website by yourself and make it
stand out with a beautiful website by
Squarespace head to squarespace.com for
a free trial and when you're ready to
launch use the offer code I owe you to
save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or domain that's squarespace.com
enter code I owe you Ryan what is it
squarespace.com entrecote I owe you I
owe you inside of you is brought to you
by CBD MD I'll tell you man CBD
companies there's a lot of companies out
there everybody's making their CBD but
you know who needs CBD you know who
knows about CBD the most people who
suffer like myself I use CBD MD because
I am in pain folks all of these other
CBD companies claim to be the best but
now Ryan mm-hmm Rosenbaum has spoken the
people have spoken the 20/20 product of
the Year Award winners have been
received and CBD MD products
to CBD categories boom
CBD PM took home the award for best CBD
sleep aid CBD fries roller which I have
like 18 in my house won top honors in
the CBD topical category so look if
you're curious about CBD if you're on
the fence or if you're drowning and
misinformation these products are the
perfect place to start
safe I think people think that you know
they're getting weed right I mean you
it's part of it I think that's the the
thing the allure is is like oh you know
everybody's the pot is it I don't I
don't want to smoke this isn't not that
I use this all the time I've had seven
surgeries listen to me I know what I'm
talking about you could tweet me later
and go hey I used it I liked it and also
yeah exactly to give CBD md's
award-winning products to try they're
offering our listeners 25% off your next
order when you use the promo code Z B T
that's zebra beta topless zbt at
checkout once again at CBD MD comm promo
codes EBT for 25% off your purchase of
superior CBD oil products from CBD MD
look something happened something like I
mean you say in the documentary but it's
like wow did it just happen like that
where he's like I feel it there's this
presence there's something that hit me
there's something that changed my life
and it causes you to just split
something that's so big bigger than you
successful money everything and there's
something that you just felt was it as
something that took a little time to
make that decision did it take months or
was it like I feel this all of a sudden
it's I'm enlightened
I've gotta go it was a few weeks maybe
two or three weeks it's a blur but I was
going to the church and I was I liked it
I was like okay well if there's a
supernatural help then I don't have to
do it all I can have help right but
after like two or three weeks what
happened was at my house the whole thing
is love I felt loved from another realm
come around me into my soul into my mind
it's a mystery honestly it's a mystery
and some people experience it some
people don't
it awakened to being enlightened to me
just like you said and it was like
everything changes now I'm not gonna be
the same person and I knew it tonight
and I did struggle with it like for
another week or two with I found some
more dope and my I did relapse yeah I
found my relapse I was going to church
and I was like I'm doing great and one
day I went home and I opened up my I saw
a first-aid kit in my closet you know
tweakers they hide things and oh yeah I
opened up the first-aid kit
and out rolls an 8-ball of crystal meth
I had somebody ate some gauze that's not
that's not a band-aid for my and then
you just snorted it down I just went for
it yeah I was like you still go to
church or whatever
oh I disappeared my phone was no one
could get ahold of me and then a week
later I was like man this I wasn't
having a good time on it anymore it was
like I felt guilty I felt guilty because
I made a decision that I wasn't gonna be
this anymore
then I felt guilty because I felt like I
was letting people down people trying to
help me and you know if God wasn't was
in me living in me now and I'm one with
him I felt guilty for that so who's just
done and then at the end of that that
week is actually it was at the end of
that I don't know it's a blur all I know
is that was the last time I did dope and
I found a little bit more a couple weeks
after that third or I threw it away
took pictures just like your camera
yelled and I poured it well actually it
was a lot of stuff I was it was like in
my first book
I'm pouring in my toilet and it's in my
book and you could hear it if you know
no no no there's audio to it
now but you didn't have a transition in
you know that's that's brave that's
strength right there that's string it
really is now use you as a little girl
it's it's hard to like going hey so I
was a three year old what were you you
obviously got to a certain age where
you're like I'm sort of [ __ ] up mm-hmm
you know no matter what something
started happening you started like
acting out right you started doing
things wanting to get attention which
everyone does no matter how old you are
and especially at a young age
if you feel sort of like did you feel
abandoned as a child absolutely well one
I experienced the trauma of my my mom
leaving and then the trauma like there
were times where I'd wake up in the
middle of the night and he would be on
he would be on his computer tweaked out
and it would make me cry I'm like why
aren't you asleep and so there was some
I went through a trauma and so when
you're a kid you just go through the
experiences but I think when you hit
eleven twelve tween tweent
you start to realize those things hurt
you're not just experiencing anymore you
look back and you're like out that
really hurt like I feel I feel damaged
because of it and so I really fell into
depression I would say just like the
signs of just like sleeping all day and
whatever and what was it so you
like all right my dad's not really there
you're growing up mm-hmm
he's trying whatever but he's you know
you're still seeing the addiction you're
still seeing things you're saying your
mom's not present being hot from house
to house and not having like the the
bonding that I needed to be like a
successful child I guess I'm on grandpa
were they pretty solid I saw them once a
week ish but the problem was that there
was some stuff that went down in the
house that I was staying at he didn't
really know but the the parents were
going through had really bad anger
issues and and drinking drinking and
there was some like sexual abuse with
the kids this was a random family that
you were living with no it was the
people that that he knew on the road and
so there was there's just there's just
some stuff and you were witness you were
privy to a lot of this [ __ ] you were
seeing when you see things as a child
especially when you're getting older I
mean this I know it's it's with you yes
there's certain things that you can
remember vividly from when you're I'm
tell you when I'm six when I'm eight ten
I mean you know obviously gets more
vivid as you get older but you know I
could see in the documentary how you're
spiraling and it's like you're reaching
out you're crying for like help me I
want I need love well I didn't quite
understand why I was hurting I knew that
I experienced all these things but I
didn't I I almost forgot what hurts so
bad and so all I knew was that I was in
pain and I wanted to die so I grew up in
the age of social media and self-harm
was a big thing and Tumblr and whatever
people would post and so me and my
friends all were in broken homes and
whatnot and so we would we would talk
about cutting and burning the flag
lighters and stuff it was almost like a
competition like oh yeah well my life
sucks so I did this and I wrote fat on
my on my thigh and oh yeah well my dad
yelled at me yesterday you know I'm
saying like it was like Brian letting
you do whatever you sort of wanna did he
have like no there are no guidelines no
discipline like be home by 10:00 did you
have to be home at 10:00 our life was
kind of crazy like there were we would
travel and stuff and I would be on the
road with him when he went sorry let me
backtrack when he left corn he started a
solo project
Brian had Walsh man
later was love and death and they would
play shows at bars and little clubs and
stuff and I would I would go on the road
and be doing homework at like 3 a.m. so
my life was a little different in that
way I would say like he tried to be
strict and be like the dad and whatever
but our life was too inconsistent that
it didn't it wasn't that she didn't have
it wasn't like we lived in a town and
her friends were in town and she could
go and then hang out till 10:00 it was
like hey we're going on the road this
month next month dad I want to go to
Phoenix and visit my friends cuz we just
live in Phoenix and so I'd fly her out
there and talk to the parents so they're
gonna be good and then you know and then
she got into some stuff that way but
when did she start lashing out when was
it like you know the whole I hate you
I'm tired too you when did you know like
you've got to step up how do you sit
there and say hey you need help when
you're the one who needed help for so
long and how does that give you any kind
of validity right was she always
questioning that she was questioning a
lot what do you think thirteen and a
half or something yeah I would say um
when I hit seventh grade I really
started to hurt you know I really
started to experience the pain of things
but yeah I started to I think voice a
and lash out and really self-harm when I
was 13 and were you devastated by this
yeah totally because I you know I tried
to discipline her but like I'd say give
me your phone you're not gonna have it
for a couple days and then she'd say
okay I'm doing my homework now I'm doing
it and then she would do it and say come
on I did it I'm not gonna do it no more
to her and she would say please you know
like Bart Simpson keeps repeating okay
you don't remember that well I would
never hold the discipline yeah I was a
good manipulator yeah and this is hard
because a time you felt like you you
gotta left it all you want to raise your
daughter you're having this relationship
well I guess this is at this point when
did you leave the ban in 2005 dude
though 2005 and you kind of rejoin like
that [ __ ] started you started touring
with them a little later right
yeah like eight years later when she was
14 almost 15 so it was a long time
I know it's kind of it's crazy story
right it's like it is crazy it's hard to
keep up with the timeline
yeah and it's just like you know you
have it's especially like when you you
found yourself and you found God and all
these things and then you have a
daughter that's acting out and then
she's you know she wants attention and
she's suffering and she's hurting and
it's like again how do you not fall back
into that and you're like I kind of did
this for you in a way but you understand
fully what she's doing and why she's
doing it and these are her feelings and
she's had these deep so it's very I mean
it probably takes a lot of therapy where
you guys go to therapy together we we
tried therapy yeah she wasn't really
having it and I feel like kids in sorry
me cutting you off I feel like kids who
have attachment issues therapy doesn't
work because bonding is scary and and
the only reason the only reason you
would you would tell your feelings to
someone or the only reason they would
want to know is because they want
something from you it's not just because
they care about you and so therapy
scared me and why would I tell this
woman that I don't even know all these
things that happened to me and and what
if she what if she snitches on me you
know what if I tell her something and
then I get in trouble you know and so it
just it just didn't work I did you feel
like you were absolutely a hundred
percent honest with her yeah no I mean I
tried to be but you know what I did I
carried around so much that that
self-hatred I had when I was growing up
it was and then I couldn't get together
had so much rage and anger problems and
I remember she said one day she was like
I said I'm sorry you know because I blew
up and she's like you're not sorry if
you're sorry you wouldn't keep doing it
but that's you don't understand I can't
stop doing I can't control myself my
anger sometimes you know how bad I want
to I want to but she couldn't comprehend
it at 40 she's probably thinking well if
you can't control yourself and if you
can't why are you telling me to control
myself yeah like she didn't respect when
I would say okay you're gonna do this or
did it as a parent it's like she didn't
respect that because I was such a mess
you know it was like we're brother older
brother and sister something right and
she just wanted a dad in a way right I
mean in a lot of ways and I'm just all I
had was the the
massive love for her everything else
discipline and and I just didn't have I
didn't have sorry no I can see you're
getting emotional now while you're
getting it doctor talk to me about that
sorry no I think it's important well I
think from the from the start just you
you don't really when you go through
trauma like that like being being left
alone with skinheads and your mom
abandoned to you and leaves you as a 16
year old and her boyfriend at 4 days and
your dad comes home and you you know you
you have from house to house a house it
takes years and layers to like really
heal from that and so I guess hearing it
again was really hard just just
accepting that that that happened to me
is hard talk about but it's it's hard to
hear it it's hard for me to talk about
it it's hard sometimes that's why it's
so important what you did that's what
doc you marry support that's why it's so
important that you're here because
you're fighting through the pain you're
fighting through it to show and I just
think it helps so many people who are
going through this [ __ ] there's so many
have what my father daughter issues and
mommy issues and all these things we all
have it most of us have it and for you
guys to open up about and show the world
you have to do whatever it takes you
know you go and you therapy you finding
God or anybody finding whatever it is
that helps them and you going to
somewhere like the youth center which
you made some big changes and found
yourself that's like that's brave that's
[ __ ] to me that's exactly what I'm
doing the show
come on and you know it's good to feel
and maybe that's another layer that yeah
I've got you know touched and healed and
everything and so so it's and it's good
for for people to see that it's okay to
feel you know because people yes Barry
yeah they bury this stuff and that's
right yeah they try to just well that's
the past
to pass well if you keep pushing it down
we all know what that brings it doesn't
bring nothing good when you push
everything down and we also it you know
it's all it's all really about shame
isn't it it's all about you feel so
shameful you don't want to talk about it
you don't want to bring it up you know
it hurts the other person it hurts you
so you just keep pushing it down and
what does that do what that does I've
done it it manifests itself and you
start to act you start to have physical
problems like mental stress things come
out I have things that I'm like you know
I'm gonna try Reiki you know Reiki is
against I pronounce that right it's like
an energy healing oh yeah because I've
had so much so many surges which we've
talked about all the [ __ ] it's just like
you know I don't care what it takes I
want to feel better I want to heal
myself I'll do whatever I'll go to and
you know how Andy Kaufman in that movie
man on the moon you know he thinks that
this guy is this masterful healer and he
knows it's not real but he just has hope
that somebody out there can help him is
Reiki dry needle no it's all--it's I
don't think so I don't know a lot about
it but it's really energy like healing
like this okay hands on like emotional
stuff and like because we and I'm trying
it cuz I've heard enough from people
saying hey try it you know many people
said do acupuncture is gonna help you
and it didn't really help me a ton and
then what I end up doing I end up going
put getting put under and get Manistee
Jie and getting feeling good for a
couple hours and I'm injecting my spine
and then doing it all over again and you
know doesn't really help right but it
does feel good to not be in pain for a
little while I just think a lot of it is
mental I think I do at this point in my
life I feel like a lot of pain that I
have is stress is the certain underlying
thing that the things from childhood
things from that I am trying to work out
that I'm trying to get out of me it's
almost like a [ __ ] Exorcist man right
I want somebody to I see you I see both
last week I felt like that yeah I had a
meltdown not like a massive meltdown
like before but I was just like yeah
like I was talking about in the kitchen
with you it was like I just want simple
why am I getting this why am I getting
that it's just making me stressed
I just want to chill I want simple condo
talk I'm glad you brought that up
because you guys he was talking about
God want things to be simple and you
know when you were with corn it was so
much that definitely wasn't simple right
although you disappeared in drugs and
all these things but then you you said I
found what I'm looking for you know I
found religion I found God and then you
know I just want a simple life I don't
want to be busy all the time
I just want to and then all of a sudden
you're like okay I'm getting a little
bored now needs something else and then
you're like then all of a sudden you
start to do all these things again and
it comes out and and then you're too
busy again yeah so it's a cyclical back
and forth thing of light do you want to
really live a simple life you know it's
a balance it's a tug of war but it's
like hey this is my schedule for the
week I'm gonna go talk on this dip shits
podcast for an hour with my daughter and
then when I leave that I'm gonna go sent
a friend monkeys has a baby and then you
know I'm gonna go get some lunch with my
daughter
and then tomorrow I'm gonna go to church
and then here's my schedule for the week
but I'm gonna do as much as I can for
myself as I am with work because you
know people who say I'm not my work so
if you're doing too much and pulled in
diversity it's just like the drugs right
it's just like you have the decision to
go [ __ ] it no I don't want to go do
another podcast I don't want to do this
I'm taking the day off I'm gonna sleep
in late I'm gonna go see a movie by
myself or with Jenaya
and that's just the [ __ ] way it is is
this is my world so we all have that
choice yeah yeah and it's just do when
it's just going I can't man it's like
during Christmas we're we were like
every it's her break where she's just
free to do something for a couple school
some work all of that take two weeks yes
so we're always like okay we're going we
always come to California we're gonna go
to Disney World we're gonna do the
little this year we were to Vegas we
went to Baker soil she went to Phoenix
and went back to Nashville and it was
just like next year we're not doing
nothing we're just gonna bake yourself
in grandparents but then when next year
comes what's it gonna be like well we do
have two weeks off maybe we can't go to
Vegas to just you know what I'm saying
you're right it's that balance it's like
you want rest and then you forget
you want to adventure - yeah it's you
know it's it's tough while watching the
documentary and it's it fills me with a
lot of hope and I think it'll give
people a lot of hope because it just
felt like is this gonna be one of those
doctors I know you didn't die at the end
of the document but at the same time I'm
like you know if I didn't know anybody
should turn this on I didn't know
anything about you know Mike you know
how is he gonna get out of this right
and how is she gonna survive she's gonna
be [ __ ] up how many times have you
looked at a kid some other kid from some
other family go that kids [ __ ] like
man poor kid his parents suck or his
parents can't get it together and he's
acting out he's doing all these things
and it takes so much work like for that
kid not to be it's just sick focused and
everything and I mean there's a lot of
people have been through like a lot
worse than we have that have been told
okay you know you just got to want to
fight through it you wanna you have to
want to process you know process it
because every family's broken in some
way yeah small large broken is broken
you know there's issues I know what I
thought something funny
out of all this funny stuff we're
talking about but I was thinking every
time I look at a rock star and I look at
their lives and I look at you and I'm
like seeing all the drugs that you've
done I know for sure I never would have
made it as a rock star really I would
have died day one I was mama's first
concert out here at Madison Square
Garden and he's dead I don't even know
how it is you look at you guys and you
guys aren't fat pigs you're like skinny
rockers long hair and you're just
drinking and drinking and doing drugs
and I'm like I do one hit of a [ __ ]
hybrid mostly of indica which means I
always remember into couch so you're
mellow like you're just into couch
mellow and I'm in the next day I'm like
I can't get it together I just got to
make it to the counter for a burger with
my friend I'm solely for some reason
drugs just I can't do something like I
don't even look at I couldn't even
imagine doing one week on tour with you
guys
matching what you guys are doing I mean
you were always drunk always on drugs
right there was no reality really other
than just not always on drugs
always drinking yes how many drinks do
you think you had a debut si
measure it in a fifth of vodka if there
was a fifth of vodka do you think you
drank a fifth of vodka day
what's a fifth is that fifth like one of
those big bottles that go like that it's
not the giant lead book someone small
but not the pint
oh yeah probably probably something like
that a fifth so roughly you know five to
ten fifths a week how did how did you
have health problems or seven did a
doctor ever say your liver is done well
you undertake to they were young they
were yeah 20-something mid 20s late 20s
I stopped in my early 30s yeah
so I'm sure there was damage yeah and
all these and all these guys still
drinking that much no god they're all
slowed down family men they're all
married have kids and yeah I mean um
there's a few that that drink wine every
once in a while toothed drummer purple
tooth Wow
1:00 a.m. he's like there's purple and
our bass player has some beers every
night but uh but not they control it
yeah yeah no drugs really in the band
no no just like a couple of a balls a
week do you think there's corn corn fans
going just going and of course now who
gives a [ __ ] what they think it was they
were young these your family everybody
was young you were doing something you
found your way and you're lucky you're
not dead
yeah we're just people man so if they're
like that then I don't really care for
did you think you were gonna lose and
did you notice like I am walking away
from this and I'm walking away from all
my friends who I grew up with and gave
me this opportunity and I am walking
away from all the fans who have put many
dollars in many but did you mean and I'm
thinking about that like you were did
you that come across your mind a lot a
little bit but the feeling was so
powerful that oh my gosh I know I know
that I know that I know that I know
because of that enlightenment in that
awakening that that Christ is real and
that the other side is real so I need to
focus on that and this precious little
six-year-old girl and so the fans sorry
love you fans sorry I love you band
members but your daughter's more
important well of course you know and
that's it but there was a I'm emotional
human being so I was like yeah I've felt
bad I I was like and there was a 23
million dollars
deal that they signed like about three
months after I left the band and I know
what yeah for EMI record you must jump
back alright I'm back
Here I am how much do you really love
God how much do you really think this is
helping your life that's good you could
have been out of there
many people just said you don't want
what the [ __ ] am i doing I could have
said I love God to you thank you God for
this money you know but I would have
said okay Jenaya I know I quit the band
but I'm gonna go back and another two
years then I'll be home right cuz they
went on tour more than ever because it
was one of the first 360 major 360 deal
where merch was involved in everything
right so they got the twenty three
million up front and they were doing
that that deal while I was in the band
what happened was I went I didn't tell
anybody I went and I did I went to media
and told him you know I found gone I
found God I awakened I'm lighten meant
and all that and I'm leaving the band
and so they didn't know so they're like
dude we're doing the hugest deal we've
ever done and you're out there saying
you're quitting you're doing nothing to
help this deal get signed so they they
were pissed off so do you remember cuz
you wrote a letter to the band right you
wrote an email it wasn't like you know
remember you did watch it told you I've
[ __ ] watched I watch because it was
good I didn't I would have fast forward
if it wasn't like it rocks I want to get
props to de Tori Mayo who the creative
team that put this film together they
made it that way so yeah it's really
soaks you know part of me is like did
you never not get in a confrontation
with guys going what the [ __ ] are you do
like screaming at you telling you what
are you doing leaving messages on your
phone or did they leave you alone they
just it was like a wall went up between
us and they never and never saw him I
did see the bass player Phil D about
three months after I left because his
who I knew since I was a teenager passed
away you know went to the funeral and
it's funny the funeral wasn't funny at
all it was really deep I spoke I
actually spoke kids anybody else they
need to say and I went up and I spoke I
was crying and and I went up to Phil Dee
and I was just like hey uh you know I
talked to his dad on the phone and I
said something that his dad told me and
then I go hey I just want to tell you
that your dad said and he like it was so
quiet at the funeral everybody's walking
soaked and he turned around he goes you
ain't better than me and I'm like
everybody looked at us and I'm like dude
I'm just I know I just you know I had to
leave the band you know I'm just telling
you what he said and that was it did you
imagine the pain that he was going
through though like if like his father
left and and then you know it's so fresh
that he it was all of it combined and he
flew up yeah it was it was crazy do you
do you cry in front of each other
obviously you do you cry Jenelle
I'm a cancer you see them cry a lot yeah
definitely do you feel like you could
cry now more and more than ever that you
feel you're just more emotional these
days
um I allow myself to cry we were talking
about that a couple months ago something
more you got a like if you want to be a
free person internally you have to allow
yourself to cry and what how I do we
were talking about not bottling things
up yes and my thing where I I get like
I'll put on music and all I'll talk to
Christ and I'll be like you know fix me
I'm a mess and spend an hour with them
or whatever and sometimes tears will
come and tears scientifically are
healing right so they're healing and so
that helps me the emotion comes out and
I feel it it's not all the time
I'll go year without you know crying at
all it's just I know that it happens
when it's supposed to yeah I feel like
I'm more emotional too I mean I told you
I mean you know not to make you feel
like you know I'm the same page with you
by any means but you know I went to well
in the center last year that meant you
know my fit my fans know we're all the
same man and it just like you know I
just was like hey I need help man I
don't I don't know not me I don't
I'm not the best me I'm not near it I
don't I don't like me I don't love me I
don't I know there's some good guy in
there like I know I'm a good guy who
still I don't feel it and
I need help and so I went and I I
couldn't believe how emotional I was for
someone who doesn't get emotional lot
cuz my family never got emotional hmm
boy was I wrong I feel really how many
things you know and I talked about this
but like something I think you and I can
relate to is you were probably in this
youth center is that what they call the
- Youth Center it's a boarding school we
call it therapeutic boarding school yeah
right and it's like but it wasn't a
boarding school what you're thinking in
disciplinarian like you know more like
love and like hey they're appealing yes
just disciplinarian in a loving way
right and you loved it right oh my gosh
it changed my life
a hundred percent isn't that something
don't you feel like you found so much
like for me I found like I always I
think I've repeated this a few times but
you guys just I haven't talked to Jenaya
so I'm saying this you're fine
but I remember that I was doing
something and I was crying about
something and she just you know this is
great Michael you're relearning I go no
I'm not
which is why I go I'm learning I've
never learned these things that a child
should have learned when wow I never
knew this stuff it was like a new dawn a
new day I was like it was so wonderful
to start to go Wow imagine being a kid
again
but now getting all the things yeah and
but you have to I'm an adult so it's
like okay you didn't get that as a kid
[ __ ] that's okay you know what given to
yourself now ya feel this [ __ ] that you
didn't feel so you could have a real
relationships and you don't resent and
you don't hold grudges and you can just
move the [ __ ] on yeah you don't swear a
lot I haven't heard you guys swear I've
I've been swearing too much no we don't
we don't have good manners yeah we have
problems with that a little bit so we
just it's more it's more like funny like
when we're joke and we'll be like [ __ ]
but yeah
you don't do that Church though no wait
well no let me ask you this because a
lot of people this is this to me this is
the most important because again people
will always say God oh they found God
yeah I know we're all there I I did that
and I feel like you know I don't sit
here and say screw you for not believing
in God until
what an idiot you are for not having
faith so why should you sit here and
roll your eyes because I found something
that helps me in my life yeah so why are
you judging me and saying I'm not I'm
crazy now look there are extremes in
always right they're extreme atheists
that are like that's all they do is you
know it's like okay so you're an idiot
and then of the extremists that are like
if you don't do this you're gonna burn
in hell join my religion of course [ __ ]
those people and that's the way I feel
mmm-hmm but then you got people that my
friend Chris Dowling and danique Dowling
who go to a la virge in Santa Clarita or
my friend Jon Heder and his wife Kirsten
who were Mormons who don't tell me what
to do they don't do but I go over there
and have a family dinner and they
religion works for them and they have
morals and values and I aspire to be
good human beings like they are Chris
they raise a wonderful family and if
it's God that helped them do that and
their spiritual spirituality or whatever
I commend them I go to church every year
with them for Christmas and I fall in
the heater day with the Dallas okay I've
been to that church that you're gonna
speak is it rusty awesome I love it I
was just gonna say rusty and rusty
speaks he's the pastor there and every
year I'm in tears and I'm like it was
just beautifully well-spoken articulate
and fun and just real and I and I just
go these are people who just really nice
people who found something that they all
could relate to and that they love and
they believe in and look what they do
for the for the community and look what
they tell me what they do for my gosh
state so there was the shooting three
months ago remember
yep they're there they like everybody
comes to them in that community and I'm
obviously there's other people like
gathering around but you know and
they're helping the hurting man yeah and
there's hurting people and Christians
look they don't have it all together
there was a pastor there that took his
life um Justin last year saying sure
yeah and so it's four broken people
trying to help other broken people man
and it's just that they found their
thing that works and you know I found
mine and it's like Jesus said that
there's there's like two roads you know
you can get lost and extremists you know
atheist or in drugs or whatever it is or
you can get lost in religion I stay in
the mid
the road of life you know where you
don't judge people you just you know you
be yourself you you find out what what
works for you and it's worked 15 years
whatever I found which was you know
Christ in my life I'm not really a
church guy I don't go to church a lot
because my lifestyles on the road but
I'm I study like some of the Christian
mystics back in the day and I'm a
meditator and stuff like that that works
so good for me yeah you know and in the
documentary just in case there's one
more thing you're not convinced I
watched it that one of your band member
says when he saw you he just goes yeah
like that was working for him that's
what he knew yeah and monkey said that
that was towards the end of the movie I
even watched it well of course I did so
so it's like he saw it in my eyes so if
you really love someone whatever it
takes for them to find themselves to be
the best person they could be to love
themselves to want to live a lot of
times it's selfish you know I've seen
where you know even when I I came back
from the Wellness Center I'm just all
routine now and structured out doing
this I'm doing art night and I'm doing
I'm having to spell all these like
things you know even one of my friends
was like hey man maybe this was after
but he goes yeah you know it's like I'm
it's nice to see like whatever like this
and I go what do you mean I don't know
you're kind of Oh boring you know really
I guess this was post like Wellness
Center like for a couple months I was
finding myself I go I was boring Wow
and you started thinking shy don't be
boring right well it's like mm-hmm
it doesn't matter you have to just do
this for yourself right now and if you
started thinking about man you're
changed man look at you I'm like yeah I
mean it's just it gets kind of [ __ ] up
this look I really like this I know it's
been kind of going we've got it gonna
gone all over the place in a way but now
you guys have this relationship and I'm
sure it's not perfect I'm sure it's
still like you know I saw you you textin
monkey because he's has a kid and she's
kind of looking like [ __ ] come on we're
doing it oh yeah and you know do you
still have ready to go from the hotel
today do you call each other out
do you really genuinely call
each other out do you say you know dad
you're doing this and talk to you she
will call me on my [ __ ] yes and do you
agree with it usually yeah but mostly
it's just you know where she accepts me
for who I am and so I'm just a nut ball
like always goofing around and we just
kind of have fun together you know
because she's living her life she's
growing up in Indiana and I'm an adult I
do and you is it do you like him ah not
you oh I thought you asked her that if
you like your boyfriend do you that you
had a secret [ __ ] sometimes my Chris
Farley never ciliary like your boy why
would you ask that
no Brian do you like him I do he was a
first date I told him how important she
is to me and that we went through a lot
of processing to get to where we are in
life right now and just so he knows that
and he was like he really respected that
then he asked me I'm a few weeks later
or months or whatever for her hand in
marriage if they were just friends
they're good friends going on dates and
you went they were gonna take it further
and he's like do you mind if I eat like
you know what your daughter made my
girlfriend I guess official yeah cool
man
he was easy he's a sweet nice is he a
drinker
no would you you wouldn't date a drinker
would you or somebody who's addicted to
drugs no okay how could you do that
right I mean that would be just stupid
you've seen it all you know it doesn't
work yeah so you're almost doing
something that you know thank you
I mean think about that all the [ __ ]
you've been through acted and sometimes
I know sometimes people think you know
I'm attracted to guys that are messed up
I want to fix them it's gonna fail it's
gonna fail it was messed up
I wanna show and I think do that with
girls it's not just that it's it's
mutual so when you date somebody
obviously are you with someone else
no you're not but do you look for
someone who is the opposite of you
someone who listens to air supply yes
I don't date anybody man I'm just out of
love so you just you still you go out
you have fun you like you like sex you
like fun sorry about saying that for you
I just don't know I don't date I'm kind
of like a monk I like a heavy metal monk
a metal monk I just kind of like I like
to read I like to be alone I like but
when I did date like I dated this girl
from England just briefly and she was
she was really quiet and sweet so I love
that I don't like what is this tattoo
mean this is well you with the devil
then and this one here eh oh it spells
something sorry that was horrible that
was perfect I don't know I did it no no
she was just
I need somebody chill cuz I'm me too I'm
like your head I'm a head case when I go
home though I'm chill and so I need
chill and I don't need someone like and
wanting to change things whatever cuz he
loves his routine so that's a girl that
goes with the flow you have someone
sorry no I really don't have someone I
have you know I I get my doggies I have
my doggies I mean you know I you know I
see someone who's awesome but we're on
the same page like you know there's you
know it's just it's very honest where
it's like you know you you're still
finding yourself and you know I don't
know what this is but you know look I
would love I think there's nothing
better than being in love and like
having someone there for you I mean I
think you know we all deserve it you
know so you have it at one time I've had
it I've lost it I've been reckless I've
been like oh you know this is fine but
I'm not ready for this and then wow that
hurts wow that's a year of pain because
I was [ __ ] an idiot
yeah because I made a wrong decision
because of my ego or whatever and that
you suffer for it yeah
so you suffer for it so I feel like now
at my age if I found someone right now
that just was like you know this is it I
there's no doubt in my mind I'm like I'm
not gonna lose her and I'm gonna do
whatever I can in fact I go above and
beyond
I stay in things longer because I'm like
May
sure that this is not right right make
sure you no one's perfect look at
yourself you're [ __ ] definitely not
perfect you know do you back to you
Jeanette do you do you look at somebody
that's more like your dad or less like
your dad or maybe he has the heart of
your dad but you don't I think I'm still
figuring it out and figuring out you're
young I'm so young I'm chi'lan just take
care of someone unless they're taking
care of you too a hundred percent unless
they know codependency right yep
hundred percent I'm with you you have a
relationship with your mom
no we don't talk um she went through
some insane childhood trauma and she's I
never dealt with it yeah I mean she
there's no there was no opportunity
where she could you know and so so she's
she's doing her thing you know and so
it's it still hurts and I'm still like
like before like how I was emotional
it's I still get to those places in it
it's just another layer of healing and
so we just kind of like right over that
subject and then yeah we know yeah but
but I mean IIIi think it's good to talk
about it because a lot of people can
relate to it in a lot of kids and a lot
of adults really have parents who have
struggled with addiction you know and so
it's it's like this thing where they're
okay one day but then they're not okay
the next day and they do something
sporadic and oh that's just mom that's
just she just she just deals with that
and so I've learned that I I'm whole
without her can actually can I tell you
one thing it's good this is what I've
learned and this took me a lot of
therapy mm-hmm I'm not saying your mom's
crazy if you think your mom's crazy
let's just say you know people say my
mom's crazy mm-hmm
if you think that you can fix her or
change her or make her a different
person or make her the mother that you
wanted then you're crazier than she is
you have to just say this is you and I
will take as little or as much of you as
I want because I'm an adult and it's my
choice and I'm not gonna let the things
or actions that you do affect the way I
feel and you're gonna make I'm not gonna
feel guilty I'm not gonna feel anything
yeah I was a little girl I should have
been taken care of and this isn't this
is what I want out of our relationship
if you want a relationship I think I
mean that's what I did with my mother I
love my mother
but this is I I'm in charge of what kind
of relationship I want with anybody
that's good that's healthy man yes and
it's hard because sometimes people are
desperate that's nice man but just like
you're your own woman you're strong you
went through so much it's only gonna
make you stronger you deserve the best
dude someone that's you yeah you know
and that's it you know better bring it
Zach yeah I'm sure stacks a great guy
look loud crazy love is the documentary
and where can people see this it's on
Showtime right now it so you can you
know get it on demand Showtime you can
watch it when it comes on you can you
can find it on all digital platforms I
was going but therefore we did the deal
with Showtime so I'm plugging Showtime
where could we find it right now but
yeah but you can through what I don't
only want to talk about it but yeah all
digital platforms and or you can get it
through you know Brian had well it's
done and the DVDs Amazon iTunes on it
loud crazy love with a k' Wow crazy look
with K and I'm telling you I watched it
you heard this I loved it I think it's
important if you're going through any
kind of struggle if you have this
daughter father or mother whatever
relationship it's about family it's not
you I mean it's an apple how about just
like people who face adversity and have
found something that works for them and
their look this is a constant work I
don't look at the u2 and think oh
they're perfect they're fixed you're not
you're [ __ ] flawed like I am like the
rest of us be but you know what it is
you're doing something about it if
you're doing something about it that's
that's the bottom line is you're making
a step in the right direction every day
even if you feel like you're going
backwards you still see the light at the
end of the tunnel I think that's the
most important thing that we all look at
yeah so watch this documentary well
think I think the both of you this is uh
oh really quickly we're gonna do a look
this is really fast this is called [ __ ]
talking with Rosenbaum okay and these
are quick questions from my patrons from
patreon there are it's it's a school
thing it's not yeah I know about patron
so these are the some some patrons that
ask some questions Meghan al what is the
most in these can be fast you don't to
answer that you probably already answer
these so you could be quick okay
Megan L what is the most surreal
experience Jenaya had as a daughter of a
rock star the most unique or surreal
experience that you remember going oh my
god I remember I was tossed around the
crowd as a three-year-old like one of
those balloons those beach balls about
hey come here little mama yeah when I
was 4 years old it was at some some
festival or something and he was like 6
foot 5 or whatever so to see look at
this little Jamaican looking at me or
she pet dolphins at 4 months old in
Australia so maybe then it well you know
and tigers we have pictures of it it's
in the book my first book did you ever
read it did you ever look it you know
what I noticed though I will say this
cuz janae is probably thinking it say
dad yes you're saying all these things
are all true but let me come up with the
most surreal thing that I think okay go
this is geneious question right Jenaya
like dad I those were all great but
nothing will top this my dad even Snoop
right was that its new sorry I don't
know you were answering okay it's not
kind of embarrassing but my favorite
band was blink 182 growing up when I was
12 12 13 I loved pop punk that was my
[ __ ] and so we got to see blink when Tom
DeLonge was still in the band he left we
got to see them meet them backstage and
went to their dressing room and Tom's
like hey it's so good to meet you when
your dad with you yeah yeah yeah did you
like them oh I love blink I still do
really yeah Travis is my favorite
drummer on the planet yeah Barker and
her awesome guy they were all so nice
and it just I was I was I smiled he you
would say Tom DeLonge and I would smile
for the next month like being 12 yeah
she's in love with him ah but she grew
out of that
so no way Tom sicko don't even think of
pani da ni Danny I'd like to know what
musical tastes Brian Anjaneya shares or
a band or an album that they both love
if they just said that's that that's it
ariana grande we will listen to her last
night and it's like some of her songs
are cheesy for me but there's something
I've never listened to her I don't I
couldn't name one song should I listen
to breathing the song breathing looks
like because after everything she went
through with like the the
the shootings and like in the Great
Britain or whatever and everything she's
been through and hearing that song
breathing you know just keep breathing
it just gets me hey Brian will you write
that down that I should listen to Aria
grande and then cross it out if you
could listen to it I listen to breathing
she has the most incredible voice I'm
sure unreal unreal Angie if you could go
back in time and change one thing about
your life what would it be and why both
you I mean this is this is this is tough
but it's probably easy in a way but it's
tough I learned a lot from my addictions
but probably addictions you know so a
lot of goods come out of it but the
damage done to her I would have
definitely gone back and reversed I
would say same I think a lot of people
say you know the pain made me stronger
but I wouldn't wish what I went through
on anybody but because I can't accept it
and I make most of it Megan was it
difficult to rebuild a relationship with
the corne band members after leaving the
band I mean the documentary will show
you that when you watch it but it was a
it was difficult it was I mean once we
got back together after eight years it
was just easy everything was forgiven
but during I mean we were separate like
we didn't talk it was it was you ever
say let's have a group prayer I'm like
[ __ ] you Wow no never no they let me do
it like when I first when I first joined
the band we were doing it and then I
could see like the singer rolls eyes so
I was like okay we're no more prayers
before the show it's just it's like you
say the same thing every night you know
it's like and we're gonna do that
Jerry W these are just comments to
comment says Devine is my favorite angry
music song nice I listened to it when
I'm in a bad mood and sing along then I
laugh hysterically at myself and I'm
good that's so no question dude it's no
question just tell Brian Welch that and
see what he says oh that's his form of
therapy right yes he's like he gets the
anger out he screams it with the song
and then he laughs hysterically laughter
is healing too it is tears and laughter
Agnes says I want to thank you for
amazing and important music which has
helped me so many times in a lot of bad
moments in my life Agnes I'm so thankful
for you saying and that's what our
gifts in life are about right to touch
others and to help the world so I'm glad
you're doing better this has been a real
joy what's your Twitter or Instagram
handles know the anybody Twitter's
anymore do that Instagram is Jenaya
welch je and an EI welch down wel CH and
don't cross it out and yeah Instagram
Brian had welts one word Brian with the
I facebook.com slash Brian ahead well
Brian hey what's done yet all that self
and then loud crazy love crazy with a
Kade calm also on a plug um that the
boarding school that I went to we are
starting a campaign to raise money for
kids and the foster care system in in
single-parent homes
so that's awakening youth org I love it
yeah we're talking about doing a
fundraiser concert and everything
because they need to get licensed by the
state of Indiana and they've done it
privately for so many years but they're
awesome school so hopefully that will
expand and where can they go if there's
a kid out there listening or a teenager
or even somebody how old what's that
what's the if you want to go to where
you went it's a boarding school for
women for girls but how 13 to 23 and
then they're also launching a boy's
program and so so yeah the the the
fundraising will that that will help
sponsorships that will help get them
licensed as a group home that will help
build the facility and everything but if
someone needs to talk like a young talk
yeah they can totally just contact them
you know someone with know what's the
name of the place again um Awakening
youth org organ they can go there and
they can ask questions and if they're
interested or their parents or yeah if
you're 21 22 23 if you're maybe 24
it might even sneak absolutely who knows
I appreciate this candid open talk you
mean I could talk to you guys forever
but I really enjoyed this this is fun I
know it's hard like you know I don't
know you for [ __ ] and so now after
watching this and talking you I felt
like during this thing it's we all
started getting like alright this is you
know it's hard it's hard to gain trust
cuz I'm like you know I'm a guy that's
interviewing you and I think with what
schools you notice I've been through
[ __ ] you've been we've all been through
[ __ ] and I think the relatability is
important I can connect with people
pretty damn fast yeah honestly and I
think talking about
with so many people being so open its we
don't have really walls up we just go in
but it was it was awesome I love the
humor and I loved it yang said the
deepness of the conversation so it's a
great mixture I love what I'm doing
brother thank you for having us thanks
Yura did you by the way did you ever
when you first left the band did you
ever read the comments people were
saying about you know you and what you
were doing did you did you get absorbed
did you absorb all that it just but what
do you hear things like oh now that you
went from corn to candy corn or like
what kind of [ __ ] did you go through
like here and all kinds of it it was
dirt but some of it is one guy one guy
said oh I wish he would have died on
meth rather than to find Christianity
and I was like well that's nice and yeah
it's just stupid but uh but value it's
all it is yeah it hurt and then some so
I stopped reading the comments cuz it
hurt too bad you know yeah like you'd
have ten good ones and one horrible ones
later that one and it would like sting
you there's a good start it's like a
dart in your emotions yeah all right
that was that was amazing thank you for
allowing me to be in darts at a dart in
your emotions why not a knife I called
my cigarettes darts guys going out to
smoke a dart never know there must be
some Indiana [ __ ] you should know Jenaya
Brian janilla thank you for allowing to
be inside of you today Kim Oh weird well
that's the show yes called inside of you
oh thank you
[Music]
that was intense man that was an intense
freakin interview and when they cried I
was like oh [ __ ] he's like way to go
Rosenbaum and I'm like [ __ ] I just I
don't know what it is man I just I have
a sensitivity to me I feel where
someone's going and I just knew that I
see her eyes welling up I'm like oh no I
gotta back off but I wasn't I don't
think I was too much I was just talking
yeah I think they really enjoyed it and
that's what I like at the under like hey
thank you for opening up and thank you
for you know it felt comfortable and
that made me feel good did you like it
yeah that was a riveting it really was I
was just I was floored by the way next
week is the first video uh-huh so this
is it I mean next week you guys are
gonna hear guests that I think you're
gonna really enjoy and a great job Ryan
for the first editing job and it's he's
been working his ass off and you know we
don't pay him that much here I thought
we were but apparently his hours were
longer than he's a perfectionist but
we're working on ways to minimize his
work if you like the editing let Ryan
know and you know we're thinking of
different ways of doing things but your
input always helps you're gonna save
some Ryan no you weren't
no no literally just think about oh we
get a lot of I gotta think about the
next one [ __ ] I know let's all gonna pay
off I think so I you know the more
successful this podcast becomes you know
I you know I just want to be able to
keep dealing it man but you know you got
to pay people like Ryan who's for Super
Talent
so hey a big shout out to all my patrons
right real quick these are the the top
tiers whoo
you know I love you all but these guys
give a lot of money man so I mean every
cent is a lot of money to give anything
is a lot of money but I really
appreciate the support and it helps pay
guys like Ryan right what Allison L
Andrew see Angelina G Lee Barry L love
them Bob believe it or not Bobby bautex
Chris Dion k Emily K Emily s Emma
H Jason de Jason W don't get those
[ __ ] confused
Jerry W Jill e Kevin R Kristen K Lauren
G Lee s highly or Leah just kidding mark
a Michael asked Nancy D Niek go P ROG my
ROG Robert B Sarah V Scott B Sean W
Tiana Tricia you wanna say this with me
you Kiko I love you kid go so I want to
thank all the all the patrons for really
hooking it up who sponsor the show or
subscribed to the show and give extra
money and you get a bunch of good stuff
and those top tiers are gonna be getting
a little care package here soon
you got a Q&Q a with me I'm doing this
week just a lot of good stuff and
they're very insightful and they get a
lot of input they get to you know ask
questions to guests sometimes and blah
blah blah all right I'll be in Richmond
or yes I'll be in Richmond this weekend
coming up I'll be in Mexico and March
look up on the the socials make sure you
subscribe please guys I say all the time
but it really helps if you're listening
and you know ten people make them
subscribe the live podcast in Austin
Texas with Zack Levi my first live
podcast please come support me let's get
a sold-out show let's have a great time
you know I'm gonna do it I'm gonna work
it and make sure you go to inside of you
live.com you can also go to margin
Walker presents comm $25 tickets get
them now early bird special
me and Zachary Levi we're gonna do some
fun stuff and so there's that and I'm
doing stage it next weekend so make sure
you go watch that live listen to some
music with Jason Mane's and myself
little left on Laurel music and
everything else if you feel like
donating to Ronald McDonald House of Los
Angeles or any Ronald McDonald House or
echoes of Hope for foster youth or food
on foot for homeless they're always
welcoming that you know what I mean you
know what why don't we end this with a
little fan letter this is some Natalie
hey Michael this might get a get long
but I promise it's worth the read I came
across your podcast in November 2009
I was looking for something new to put
on while I worked I bounced around a lot
of episodes thoroughly enjoying every
story that came to me from you and your
guests I get hooked pretty quick however
I avoided Jennifer Love Hewitt episode I
avoided it like kryptonite for two
months
she's quite possibly always been one of
my favorite people so it was hard to
stay away the reason I did was that I
lost my mother my name is Kathy and I'll
be three years and May sorry Natalie
since she's been gone she took her own
life after several different failed
attempts over the course of what it
seemed to be rapid six months I knew
that I would have to save Jennifer's
episode for when I needed it a good cry
the good day came a month before my 30th
birthday mom always made a huge deal
about all our birthday starting a month
out so I I could feel that I need a cry
coming anyway even though I was at work
I took a deep breath and I hit play I'm
not exactly when I say that I did my
work in tears once she started talking
about her mom I had to try not to ugly
cry when Jennifer spoke about getting
the call my younger sister was the one
to find our mom like she did and ended
up being the one to call me the rest
feels like a blur through somehow I made
it through the flight there I remember a
good amount of everything 600 people
showed up to her viewing 600 people who
loved her we're all healing in our own
ways I had a little baby girl in Maine
our son plays hockey and loves it
knowing our daughter will never meet my
mom is hard my mom and our story is a
topic I could discuss for days if you
let me so I'll stop here for now
I just want to say a huge thank you for
always being so candid on mental health
Michael my mom would have loved you I
hope I can somehow help others the way
you do one day also a thank you to
Jennifer Love Hewitt she helped me
realize that it's okay to still grieve
even after a long time there is no time
stamp on grief and I'm gonna take my
time with this if you do end up reading
this on the podcast which I am thank you
to the listeners for sticking through
this long email hug your parents your
spouses significant others kids fur
babies plant babies hug everyone as long
as they're cool with it and just know
you're not alone happiness can be found
even in the darkest of times if one only
remembers to turn on the light that was
Dumbledore who said that
best wishes Natalie Natalie thank you
that's a great way to end the podcast
thanks for being so strong and sharing
such a personal story with us and you
guys I appreciate you more than you know
I don't even think you know I much
appreciate you thank you for listening
thank you for allowing to be inside all
of you from Ryan taya's and myself
that's me
we'll see you soon
[Music]